[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions is
george's wife on the debt-free stage
george you're supposed to be out there
oh all right then well uh you need to
get moving all right i'll get on the
other side dave give me a moment all
right i'm going to fill for george while
he
makes it out to the debt free stage
he's torn between being a co-host and a
husband and
[Laughter]
so
we'll get him trotting out there and uh
yeah pretty good hustle there george
that's good all right so george and
whitney are with us on the debt-free
stage and uh somewhere around seven or
eight hundred ramsey solutions people
george you're costing me about fifteen
thousand dollars a minute here
i knew you were doing the math i don't
even know half of these people they're
just here to not work
hey you shouldn't say that about people
celebrating for you all
all joking and cutting up aside george
and whitney are here to do their debt
free scream the first ramsey personality
to ever do a debt free scream and uh
this one's really special how much did
you guys pay off we paid off a little
over 165 thousand dollars oh 165 000 and
how long did that take
about 26 months 26 months
and oh by the way what kind of debt was
that it was the house
house and everything
i'm looking at weird people we are weird
and i mean that so literally
you guys are incredible congratulations
well we have a rule with team members
obviously we're not going to ask your
income since both of you work here that
would be highly irregular and
uncomfortable but uh pretty cool stuff
george during the time you guys have
been by getting married meeting each
other buying a house you've both been
working here getting the debts paid off
and then uh buying a house and turn
around knocking it out tell the story
yeah so we met here uh you know back in
2015 when whitney started
and uh in 2018 we got married and we
started off our marriage debt-free
thanks to the principles here i had 40
000 in debt when i started back in 2013
as an intern and i came in just learning
this stuff going through fpu and decided
you know if i'm gonna work here i guess
i should like do this stuff and see if
it actually works and so i got out of
debt in two years and in 2018
we got married and we just had some
weird goals you know being here around a
lot of weird people and so when it came
time to buy our first house we were
renting for a little bit we just had
this weird goal of let's see how much we
could put down for a house and then see
how quickly we could pay it off
and so that's kind of how the whole
thing started and we were really just
dreaming together saying what do we want
our life to look like do we want to work
till 65 do we want to have options do we
want to go on incredible trips and what
could we do without a mortgage payment
so that's really what started that
journey 26 months later the house is
paid for from the time you buy it that's
pretty freaking incredible
and uh whitney uh you guys are truly
opposites of track george loves the
spotlight you detest it that's true
you and i were in a meeting earlier
today and you're like i'm not sure i'm
excited about yeah
i'm here
you're here you're here now she she's uh
more of the eye candy so she deserves
the spotlight i got a face for radio
next to you
ah good move well played well played
well played but whitney um now that
you've done all of this and you've been
you guys have both been here for a long
time you've been plugged into this whole
process
now that you're actually there how does
it feel
i feel like it's still
surreal we kind of became addicted to
paying off
the mortgage like each month we would
look at what is extra in our budget and
we would do a lot of no spend months
which i know that sounds miserable to
most people but it almost was like a fun
challenge of what are the things we need
to buy
and what can we
you know not do the things that we want
to do and that just helped like expedite
our goal and get
our mortgage knocked out faster but
y'all were a little bit too intense
actually yeah you say you don't need to
be gazelle intense and i was like no
we're and she was more intense than i
was i found an iphone note from 2018 the
month we got married and i already was
doing the math on how much we were going
to put down how quickly we were going to
pay it off and we had this wild he
nerded out yeah oh yeah completely out
that hurts he's the numbers guy that's
so cool yeah that's good we have a goal
to pay it off in four years that was our
big hairy audacious goal we're gonna pay
this thing off in four years and whitney
said nah that sucks we could do it in
three i took my breath away
throw down the gauntlet baby yeah so and
two years and two months later boom
just like that just like that so what's
the first big thing you're gonna do to
celebrate
well uh dave we talk about this on air
about how crappy my car is yeah so
upgrading the car uh we're talking about
it
that's true it's hurtful but it's true
no it's just true it's not a personal
thing it's just crappy yes so that's our
a1 and then we would love to pay cash
for our next house and upgrade and into
something a little bigger as a as maybe
we have a family one day no announcement
sorry if that uh you know everyone
excited there we do have a dog so i am a
dog dad which that word alone makes john
delaney he's standing yeah
yeah don't say dog dad but you have a
dog but you you are you you are one of
those people because you you know french
bulldog people are all that way so you
you brought the dog for the debt-free
scream right he did it wasn't my idea it
was the entire team's idea yeah
they said hey we'll dog sit we're happy
to do it right you got a whole bunch of
dogs here well let's get uh the dog
is here with us today
you know her name's suzanne sims she's
one of our board members
[Music]
all frenchies do
oh my gosh that's just way cute
i think this might be the first this is
the first this is the first dog no i
think we had a service dog one time
olives is not a service dog no she's
special requires service but she's not a
service dog yes oh the only thing more
high maintenance than olive is me
i'll say that
so it's funny that is great well uh
since you're talking about moving up i
think it is a good idea just to point
out that yeah you're a big time ramsey
personality both of you work here uh but
you're not making two million dollars a
year neither one of you yeah i hope you
do something today thank you not yet
speak that over here and uh uh uh the
the other thing
so your home is modest you're newlyweds
it's a town you're young yeah you just
got married you bought a town home do
you want to tell what it's worth or not
you don't have sure yeah it's uh it's
worth about 480. okay all right and it's
paid off in 26 months and you guys have
been married
three years three years over three years
okay so very very cool well it's good
that our ramsey personality is an
example of the things we talk about in
so many ways but it's not like a four
million dollar house and you know on the
beach or something like that this is a
it's a it's a modest good starter home
and like you said the next good big goal
save up say move up in that and before
you do that get out of that crappy car
yours yes and the big thing dave was the
the walk the talk this initiative we had
in 2021 with our whole team to have this
huge 25 million dollar turnaround of
debt paid off dollars saved and so that
just fired us up seeing all of the
stories around this building of people
that were paying off debt leveling up in
the baby steps and it just reminded me
of why we do this and my passion for
this and you know whitney was a huge
part of that too just getting fired up
about how much faster can we do this can
we do it before walk the talk is over uh
in 2021 and so we made it by the skin of
our teeth there you go well thank you
guys both for who you are as people
thank you for who you are as an example
as a ramsey personality and as a couple
here and both of you working on the team
uh are excellent excellent team members
and um good friends and we're just so
proud of you you guys are just amazing
george has gone all the way from intern
through about six or seven different
positions over the years has worked his
way up uh learned this stuff inside and
out lived it and becomes a ramsey
personality uh in the last 24 months and
that's moving him into a whole different
realm of things he's always been on
stage not always but for a lot a lot of
the time been on stage here as a host
and other things but now he's moved into
this role and is uh you're killing it
there as well so you guys are just a
picture of success we're so proud of you
well thank you for helping me meet my uh
my wife dave i couldn't have done it
without you yeah i i had nothing to do
with it except payroll
but there you go but i think maybe my
family no did that was was whitney
involved i mean was uh uh uh was my
family involved in this whitney actually
i know this is a very organized you've
hung out you've hung out with a few of
the family members
oh yeah good friends with daniel's
daniel's wife yeah so all right here we
go guys
it's whitney and george
house and everything 165 000 paid off in
26 months and olive count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Music]